Brian collector is a former Army Special
Operations snipers the firearms attorney
and a columnist the Federalist teen
joins us and Ryan thanks coming up
thanks for beyond Tucker so I think a
lot of the people who are coming to the
March this weekend are just upset about
school shootings and maybe haven't
thought about the agenda that undergirds
the March but the people who organized
is gonna have a pretty clear legislative
agenda they'd like to do a lot of
different things and I want to run a
couple of those things by you and get
your quick responses as to whether you
think that they would they would work so
the primary one is to ban the ar-15 or
basically the whole category of
semi-automatic rifles would that have
stopped the school shootings we've seen
no so criminals don't obey laws the
definition of a criminal is somebody who
doesn't obey a law banning an inanimate
object will not solve these problems so
for example the Maryland shooting
yesterday didn't involve an air 15
Virginia Tech the used pistols the Fort
Hood massacre he used pistols 911 to use
box cutters the tool is not the problem
I mean we want to talk about tools look
at the Austin bombings that we just
solved today bombs are already illegal
it didn't stop the bombings from
happening but wait but we know because I
saw it on CNN like all week that
high-capacity magazines are the core
problem so when we ban those obviously
this will end right of course of course
because you know during the assault
weapons ban started in 1994 and
sunsetted in 2004 it did nothing to stop
violent crime in fact today is levels of
violent crime were 50% lower than they
were at their peak in 1997 right in the
middle of the same ban that banned those
so-called dangerous high-capacity
magazines well that doesn't make sense
because I know that places with strict
gun control laws are much safer
yeah so one of the things I love about
our federalist system is that we can we
can look at you know society's little
cities or states and then experiment
with laws or ways of doing things and I
think before we have serious gun control
legislation we should look at Chicago
and see how it's working there how is it
working has it stopped though they
banned shootings there so they're no
more shootings solve the problem right
no it's it's it is the worst place we
have going on right now in our country
for shootings we have not only just
shootings but a violent crime
and you don't Tucker that's another
problem is I don't know why we're
focusing on shooting so much yes they're
horrible they're bad but we should be
worried about violent crime and when I
talk to and I'm trying to debate with an
anti gunner
one of the first things I'll ask them is
look are you really trying to stop gun
violence are you trying to stop all
violence if they answer gun violence
okay I get it they're just trying to ban
guns but they want to stop all violence
okay let's have a serious discussion
because just getting rid of guns yes
maybe maybe the use of guns will go down
if you banned them but just like
Australia your violent crime is you're
going to stay the same or go up because
you have a bunch of unarmed victims so
what what about I mean one idea that
seems to be gaining traction among even
some Republicans is the idea of banning
gun purchases under the age of 21 that
doubtless would solve the problem you're
either an adult at 18 or you're not we I
think we need to make that distinction
first before we even get to guns and I
get it that Democrats want younger
voters because as people grow up they
tend to stop voting Democrat but if you
can be tried as an adult in a criminal
case at 18 if you can join the military
at 18 if you can enter into legal
contracts at 18 then you're an adult you
should be able to buy a firearm but
let's just pretend that we're gonna
raise it to 21 and we're gonna raise all
the ages for all those things I just
mentioned at 21 years old that still
would not have stopped 29 of the top 30
mass shootings that we've had in this
country well I'd be getting justice then
there's that I'm beginning to think
maybe there's another agenda here and
it's not just about stopping school
shootings right and thank you for
injecting some reason into this it's
been sorely lacking so I appreciate it
thank you